hello everyone and welcome to a few more
games that we're gonna cover from the
video World Cup fabianco 101 third place
he had uh to fight it out with Ninja
tabasov and we are going to check out
that game but first we are going to
check out the game from round four a lot
of you guys have requested this one it's
Fabiano caruana with the white pieces
against Ray Robson with black and it
features just a brilliant brilliant
attack where uh Fabi just uh completely
dismantled uh Robson with the black
pieces so let's check it out uh Fabi has
the white pieces and he opens with E4
uh we have E5 by Ray and Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to C4 five he
goes for the uh for the Italian game
with Knight to F6 the two nice defense
and of course D3 the modern Bishops
opening Bishop to C5 transposing into
the Joko pianissimo and now C3 with the
six castles and pawn to A5 stopping B4
uh also all been played before rookie
one we have best of the A7 and now
Knight beta D2 We have Ponte H6 and now
Knight to F1 uh castles by Robson and
here uh H3 is a known move uh also uh
there are some other moves that have
been played here but Knight the G3 is
what Fabi plays and it is now as of move
tender we have a completely new game and
developing the bishop to G4 doesn't
really do all that much for black you're
gonna meet it with H3 and now okay you
you can't really go here the Knight Will
capture it if you capture you already
develop White Queen you have constant
pressure on F7 so not something black uh
will be proud of so instead we have
Knight D7 Shifting the Knight over to G6
and now Pawn to H3 we have Knight to G6
and Bishop back to B3 now in expectance
of Bishop to E6 probably wants to bring
the bishop over to this diagonal so
Bishop to E6 attacking the bishop Bishop
to C2 and now Pawn to C5 stopping D4 but
not really as white does play D4 so
these are all very very standard ideas C
captures and the 4C captures and queen
to B6 now putting pressure on the D4
pawn and also preventing uh Fabi from
developing his dark Square Bishop as the
B2 Pawn will be hanging but
interestingly that is exactly what Fabi
does he plays Bishop to E3 and now uh
what do you what do you play here the
thread
one of many is D5 attacking the bishop
and the Queen and B6 uh do capture the
pawn on B2 that's the question here uh
in fact it is the best move and Ray
plays it to a queen captures on B2 uh
but uh what do you think fabi's idea was
after Queen captures on B2 uh of course
the usual stuff is Rook to B1 but he did
not play that you you could play a rook
to be one let's take Queen captures and
A2 you're gonna capture on B7 uh but
black plays Rook after B8 and uh not uh
all that much for white uh however after
Queen captures on B2 Bobby played Bishop
to B3 so temporarily giving up a pawn uh
Bishop capture some B3 with a capture
some B3 and now Queen to C3 uh preparing
to get the queen all the way back and
now comes Knight to F5 and here a very
tricky position where the D6 Pawn is
hanging so how can Robson defend it well
one way to do it is to play Rook after
d8 and this is in fact the best way to
do it but he played Queen to C7 and it
seems like a reasonable plan you you
snatch upon you go back with the queen
C7 is a very natural Square for the
black queen you also defend on these six
uh if if Rook to C1 you always bring the
queen to D7 so the pawn will be nicely
protected but Fabi had something else in
mind and that's why Rook f38 was best
keeping the queen and C3 Fabi plays
Bishop captures on H6 and here you
already feel that something has gone
terribly wrong because Fabi just won
back his pawn and if you don't capture
back the pawn then uh well you just have
a worse position so of course Robson has
to capture a g captures on H6 it is
objectively the best move and now comes
Queen to D2 by Fabi and now you see okay
maybe my queen was a little bit better
on C3 preventing this queen to D2
maneuver and also how do you stop Queen
captures on H6 followed by Queen to G7
Checkmate doesn't seem like all there's
much you can do well you can you have to
give back some material Knight to F4
prevents Queen captures on H6 and not
just five he plays G3 he even allows the
Knight captures on H3 with check but
even if you do this then king attacks
the Knight and now you have to go back
and then the pawn will capture the
Knight so it doesn't really do all that
much Fabi instead played a knight 6 the
H5 what he should have done is king th8
sorry Robson I should have played King
dh8 and now after something like d
captures D captures and G captures on F4
uh okay he's still he's still fighting
uh but after this uh G3 move he played
Knight six the H5 and now Fabi played
the G characters on F4 Knight captures
on F4 and King to H1 we have King to H7
both of them getting the Kings off of
the G file and not just a nice calm Rook
captures an A5 and now uh okay there's a
lot of pressure here on this E5 Pawn
with the pawn with the Knight with the
Rook from A5 uh how do you continue this
with black well there just aren't any
good moves it's uh it's a bad position
for black Robson played Bishop to B6 and
now his position is dead lost he attacks
The Rook but of course you guys know
that this doesn't matter feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for Fabi while I give
you a couple of seconds and sorry yeah
this is a classical game of uh sorry
about the art there
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
well tricky and clean maneuver and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is the captures on E5 that's the
move and of course capturing The Rook
doesn't do anything as now the Knight is
undefended so just Queen captures an F4
and now Checkmate will occur very
quickly uh so you could play something
like F6 maybe to control the seventh
rank with the queen but it doesn't
matter Queen captures with checking the
G8 now e captors and D6 attacks the
queen and that's it if like Queen F7
Rook to G1 check uh there are no more
moves you have to block and then you're
just gonna get checkmated so instead
after d captures on E5 I often said all
right I I admit it D captures an E5 N5
he played Rook captures on E5 and he was
in this position on move 27 that Fabiano
Corona won the game or rather where Ray
Robson resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the Knight
is no longer protected the queen will
capture the Knight on the next move and
of course you cannot move the Knight to
Checkmate the queen captures on H6
followed by Queen the G7 Checkmate there
is nothing
um Robson can do this and the sensor the
classical game the first classical game
with Robson had the white pieces ended
in a draw this is how Fabi won uh round
four against Ray Robson uh he uh took it
down in In classical time format uh so
that's what happened there uh very very
uh excellent game by Fabi now we jump
into the uh sorry about that and now we
jump into the first game uh of the
Rapids uh between Fabiano Corona and
ninja turtles have had the uh the white
pieces here for those of you who do not
remember as we did cover some of the
games from the magical one Abba so uh
his uh uh he started very poorly obvious
of absolutely demolished Fabi in the
first classical game they played and
Fabi needed a win in the classical the
force time breaks he was able to do that
and now we are going to check out the
first game of the 25 minute rapid
section uh where a ninja has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to D4 so
here ninja is coming back from A Loss
Fabi just defeated him in classical time
format and now he uh of course uh well
would very much like for that not to
happen again so Knight to F6 and Bishop
to G5 uh the trompowsky attack by
abbasov and Fabi plays something that
we've pretty much never seen here
usually you you see Knight's day four
you see E6 you see uh D5 and ucc5 so
those are pretty the top four moves you
will see against the trampolski but fire
plays Knight to C6 and I've checked the
database it's actually the 10th most
popular move at the play against Bishop
to G5 so it's a very hard to say if this
is actually in Egypt's um
um you need just opening repertoire but
okay Pawn to E3 and now Pawn to E5 and
imagine this we are on move three and
already we have a completely new game on
the board we have pointed D5 by Ninja uh
chasing away the Knight Knight the E7
and now he plays Bishop captures on F6
so he eliminates um uh fabi's Knight he
gives up the bishop pair but he messes
up fabi's Pawn structure we have Pawn to
C4 defense denaito once again at the
pawn once again D6 and now Knight the C3
uh we have Pawn to F5 Fabi has this
excellent Center for for uh getting his
Pawn structure all messed up and he
still has the bishop pair we have Pawn
to H4 by abbasov Bishop to G7 and now
even on to H5 uh Fabi Castle's King side
uh pretty pretty brave as the king side
opened up like this but obviously he
knows what he's doing and he has
prepared very well now the question is
should you play H6 here uh obviously
it's uh it's a move you play without
without thinking I mean it's it's so
good you you don't even think about
playing it and yes the engine agrees it
is the strongest move for some reason
ninja does not play it he goes for
Bishop to D3 and now C6 probably just
ignoring H6 like it's not the best move
and again it's the best move in in every
position here we have Quinta the tube in
Egypt C captures on D5 we have C
captures and now Bishop to D7 I'm trying
to pronounce his name properly ninja
because every time you turn on subtitles
uh the the YouTube subtitles say ninja
so I'm really trying here uh you know
sorry if it's not working but Knight
gte2 and now Rook the C8 we have Knights
the G3 by ninja and now Ponte E4 attacks
the bishop here Bishop to C2 and now
Pawn to B5
uh we have Bishop to B3 now putting the
bishop on this diagonal also if the
queen moves and the Knight moves the
bishop and C2 will not be a target for
The Rook uh so okay you could go B4 here
maybe but it will be a bit premature
here we have Queen to A5 by Fabi uh Rook
to C1 now if you go for let's say you
try something like Knight C2 do you
offer a queen trade because you would
really love to you know minimize Black's
pressure a little bit the problem is
just captures captures and Bishop
captures and B2 you you lose a pawn so
there's no good way to
um uh you know relieve at least some
pressure here so Rook to C1 by ninja and
now Pawn to H6 by five and now he said
all right I'm out of useful moves now if
you play H6 it's actually going to be
really bad for me uh so we have Castles
by ninja and now Rook to see five by
five he puts more pressure on this D5
pawn and now we have uh Pawn to F3 and
Egypt decides to open up the center but
now Bishop to E5 by playing Pawn to F3
the Knight on G3 has been weekend so
Queen to F2 defends the Knight now he
captures an F3 Queen captures on F3 and
now Queen to B4 yes the game is once
again decided via the B4 square and look
at this we have rooked the C2 and now
Ponte A5 the queen on B4 made Rook for a
made room for the pawn here Rook seat to
F2 doubling up on the f file but now
comes a move that well I'm not just
gonna tell you to move feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best maneuver for Fabi while I
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
foreign
that the king side is completely
demolished and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
uh Rook captures on C3 you don't have to
do it you could also play Queen Dage for
right away but this is more precise the
way Fabi did it uh beat characters on C3
is met with Queen to H4 and now you just
get uh you know completely
um uh the the destroyed here so Knight
captures on F5 was played you have to
give up the piece somehow so it's better
to at least eliminate the F5 Pawn Knight
captures on F5 and now B captures on C3
but of course Fabi again goes for Queen
to H4 we have G3 uh and now just Knight
captures on G3 of course there's no way
to avoid Checkmate now the problem is if
you play Rook to G2 which seems like a
great move it's met with just Queen to
H1 Chuck a king F2 and queen captures an
F F1 with Checkmate so after this Knight
the G3 move Rook the H2 was played
attacking the queen queen to G5 and now
Rook to G2 and now of course there is
nothing you can do uh Bishop to H3 was
played uh and now there is nothing more
for white to be to be done here so it
was in this position and move 28 that
ninja abasov resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here so
imagine that I mean here 27 moves uh
Fabi just completely destroys uh Ray
Robson and now in 28 most he completely
demolishes a ninja tabassov and well of
course now abasov got his chance to
retaliate with the with the black pieces
but of course uh he he tried a bit too
aggressive and Fabi made quick work of
him um I don't have the game here but I
will show I will just mention how many
moves it took for Fabi to beat uh Ninja
in the final game uh where ninja could
have fought back a little bit uh 29
moves
once he lost that game it was pretty
much miniature up after miniature after
miniature uh so yeah very nicely done by
Fabi and uh like I said if you have any
other games that you would like to see
from the video World Cup as of course we
haven't covered most of them do use
hashtag suggestion and I will I will
cover it definitely as we have another
big tournament coming up very soon uh
these are the uh these are the the
starting ranks from the from the Abu
Dhabi Masters it will be Magnus Carlsen
who will be the top seed and you have
anishigiri gukesh abdusator of Northern
so those are only the top 20. I think
there are uh there are 30 grand Masters
who are at least over 2600 so it's going
to be a great tournament and as you can
see Magnus are obviously not fed up with
classical chess just yet as he is
playing in this one right after the
World Cup I mean it's been a grueling
month of classical chess and now we're
gonna get more so I'm very very happy
about that hope you guys don't mind it
either
that's the game those were the games
hope you enjoyed that I would like to
thank Dennis farzato
chauduri Robert Bloom and Andrew Wooley
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
once again big congratulations to Fabi
unwinning third place in the video World
Cup uh see you soon